I think this is one of the major
unknowns about Obama.
He in some ways has to succeed within a
very traditional broadcast style of
politics and governance.
But there's also the outlines of the new
system.
And I think the new part is coming from
a fact that's actually even bigger than
Obama and our preoccupations in
electoral politics.
And that's the,
the falling costs for people with the
same interest to share information and
collaborate and find each other in the
first place.
That is what's changing the world,
the falling cost for likeminded people
or locate each other,
share information,
do something with it,
and then tell the rest of the world.
And whether you are campaign recognizes
it or not,
that is out there and it's happening.
And so there's no doubt that an American
government realizing this shift could
operate in a different way than our
government does now.
And there are people who want to make
that transition happen,
who want to see the age,
not an internet fundraising and
organizing a campaign over the web,
but something much more profound,
which would be government of the people,
by the people.
And for the people in which the people
actually have the same information
available to them that the government
has
and that kind of openness,
that kind of transparency is certainly
going to change government eventually.
But we really don't know if the election
of Obama would bring it on.
We didn't really don't know at all if he
would govern any differently then Bill
Clinton or for that matter George Bush,
it's,
it's there as a kind of a,
as a kind of a under tone
and as potential,
but the rest remains to be seen and we
have this problem about talking about
change when it comes to technology and,
and these big shifts is we ask,
you know,
whether it's going to be one or the
other where we ask it if it's,
you know,
the Internet is taking over or really
not much of a factor at all is we have
to have some more complex images here.
You know,
it's sort of like they're still running
the old stadium,
but they're building the new one writer,
you know,
right around it.
And how we function in both worlds at
same time.
The old broadcasting system is still
there for much of the country and much
of the campaign is being run through it
and then underneath it or around it,
there's this new distributed system of
sort of many to many of the politics and
media and it the two interact with each
other.
So I think we're going to continue to
see that.